hi my name is lyndon i'm seven years old
and today here are two chefs competing
to make my dream dish
[Music]
hi linda hi linda i'm alex hi i'm riya
if you were a fairy what would you eat
i would eat a shooting star with pixie
dust at the end and see just water
seems pretty right to me i'm running the
star
the shooting star what does it taste
like it tastes like
vegetables vegetables if i've learned
anything from this competition it's that
the kid doesn't always know what they
want there's also eggs eggs scrambled
and what kind of vegetable do you like
cherry tomatoes which are not vegetables
that's not what i expected rainbow the
rainbow
what does the rainbow taste like
this is ice cream oh it's ice cream
what's flavor this is strawberry
strawberry ice cream
and eggs
so the star tastes like eggs and
vegetables and the rainbow tastes like
ice cream i don't know how to combine
two things together wow beautiful
so it's our own no
whoa whoa whoa i make the drink real
fast
is it just a simple water or it's not
from water
pixie dust water what does it taste like
powerful
powerful colorful powerfulness
it's a sweet it's a sour is it spicy
sour i love love
you love sour i love summer too do you
like lemon sour like lime when she said
powerful flavor
ding i have some ideas all right
what are you trying again
the pixie dust amazing do you think
that we
can make you this drawing in a dish
you'll have to
i'll have to no choice pressure's on all
right so we're going to go all righty
going to keep drawing her that's okay
so here's my plan for the base i'm going
to use blue and a purple sugar so it
looks like nice sky for the start i'm
going to make star-shaped sandwich with
cheddar cheese cucumbers and egg and add
cherry tomatoes for the tail of shooting
star i'm going to scoop strawberry ice
cream on top of it i'm going to use
spreaded white chocolate sprinkle some
pop rocks for the drink i'm going to use
butterfly pea flour tea with lemon juice
which changes color for the star i'm
gonna do a lemon cookie with a lemon
glaze
for the shooting part i'm going to make
white chocolate brush strokes with
fruity pebbles and glitter
and i'm going to make a fairy berry
lemonade slushie with some glue on top
so i'm going to start by making my dark
cookie first i just have my softened
butter and i'm going to put some sugar
in there you want to make sure you cream
it so the butter and sugar get like
fluffy in texture
i'm going to make lemonade from
butterfry pea flowers if you add lemon
there is a chemical reaction and it
changes color
from blue to purple here in riya's plan
i am immediately worried so i kind of
put like two
tablespoons now i'm just boiling water
coming into today i have a little bit of
an idea what i'm going to do but i'm
still kind of winging it
fairy wing in it
i'm also winging it alex you are yeah
well that's good to know so now i'm
going to add in the rest of the
ingredients a half a teaspoon of salt
some fresh lemon juice some lemon juice
lemon zest can get like a little
bitter i don't want to add too much
because she's a kid
yeah add a little vanilla to the cookie
the
flour are you nervous for anything this
round like is there anything
i think i'm oddly relaxed i don't know
why i'm not i'm like
wow what's wrong with me so i'm gonna
pop my dough in the fridge let this hang
out and firm up and then we'll move on
to the next thing
the last season i lost twice it's
nothing to lose and it makes me kind of
relax and
then i start having fun maybe this is
the key of the winning
i think i'm in a good spot right now
because she did ask for egg and she's
not making it really is giving lyndon
every single thing that she wants i
didn't because a lot of the things don't
really go together but that could be
why i lose this one i decided to use
fruity pebbles to do the rainbow the
only thing is that i'm gonna have to
separate each color by hand
i'm already over this
[Music]
this was the worst idea i've ever had
at least you got the song so for the
tail for the shooting star i'm going to
spread white chocolate with spatula
nice i think i can also put pop rocks
right now because it's wet so it sticks
better
oh it's already popping
did you hear that i love can i have some
i love it
yeah this will pass the time the popping
oh my neck
see i'm having fun this time
i'm not
i'm making lemonade and i'm going to
melt sugar because i just taste it it
just doesn't taste like anything
i fully realize that i am putting a lot
of work into separating out each of
these colors
and i'm pretty sure lyndon's not even
gonna care
i did it yeah i've got my colors
thank my favorite godmother as i learned
from last competition
working with white chocolate is a little
bit difficult
so i tried to make my life easier by
buying candy melts which are essentially
white chocolate with the colors already
mixed in so you don't really have to
worry about the white chocolate seizing
up pop this in the microwave ten seconds
at a time i made a color changing
cocktail before but i've never used
butterfly pea flowers so
i'm gonna show you this is really cool
[Music]
six changes blue to puffle
a color changing drink
that is some fairy magic so what i'm
gonna try to do is put a spoonful here
and then take this brush
and kind of brush it out to make like a
shooting effect oh that's cool i'm gonna
add the edible glitter
and some fruity pebbles for powerfulness
i was worried about how the brush
strokes of the white chocolate would
turn out but i'm loving how they look it
looks exactly what a shooting star
rainbow would look like i'm just gonna
let it set in room temperature
it should set up in about like 15
minutes now i'm gonna move on to my
cookie
i'm gonna start making sandwiches
bread
cheese
cucumber
one component i forgot i'm going to add
ice cream because she said ice cream too
as far as i remember
she did say ice cream that is another
thing that i am not gonna do point relay
i'm gonna pop these in the oven to bake
at like 350 just until they're a little
bit golden on the edges
okay now i'm making omelette
it has um egg and cheese
yum so with the glaze you usually add
some sort of liquid to powdered sugar so
milk or heavy cream but because i'm
adding lemon juice it'll do the trick
easy peasy
i'm all squeezy
easy peasy lemon squeezy literally so i
got my cookies out they're looking good
just like lightly golden on the edges
i'm gonna just finish my sandwiches i
like cupid mayo this is my jam
do you want to describe what cupid is
yupi meyer is japanese mayo it tastes so
much better why
i think it's msg
to be honest with you
you know if i heard of the lie that it's
bad for you yeah
i knew that
and i want linden to know
i didn't use eggs so it's going to be an
open face sandwich
i'm going to start peeling these off
i try to be really careful so i don't
break them
hopefully this works
oh my gosh
so cool look at that
ah
better than i even imagined
plating my dish i'm so proud it's
looking so good and i think she's gonna
really like it but now i have to make my
drink so i'm just scooping strawberry
ice cream i'm gonna start with ice since
i'm making a slushie lemon juice some
sugar
the blueberries
it is kind of nice because the berries
give it like a speckled look which is
kind of like the pixie dust so it's
definitely not blue but
[Music]
wow cool oh it looks great
we did it yeah
well i'm not very sure who's going to
win this one but
let's go find out yeah
i'm happy how it turned out it's
colorful it looks awesome it looks so
cool and i have my secret weapon which
is my color changing drink i'm super
confident at this point i really didn't
know what was gonna happen today but i
am so proud i didn't give her every
flavor she mentioned but it looks spot
on to her picture i am very optimistic
bring on the very face
what is that well that looks like a
shooting star sandwich
and oh this looks like two diminished
no it smells funny
[Music]
oh changing colors
what this is
i cannot see her facial expression but
that's the sound i wanted to hear
[Music]
and i feel so powerful
there's a cuckoo bird
with egg on top
[Music]
all righty
[Music]
i suddenly realized i don't know if she
had pop rocks before i hope she likes it
what are those noises in my head
it
this strawberry ice creams
can you just eat all this yeah do you
like that
whoa
oh it's glittery over here
whoa
that came out flying
it tastes like a cookie
[Music]
definitely it's definitely a cookie
with
lemon right there
i can't really see what's happening but
it sounds like she's liking it
i love lemon stuff
when is
[Music]
you know what i bet fairies poo glitter
so i'll take that one
you like it
and that's how you drink like a adult
all right so
lyndon which one did you like sandwiches
ice cream or a cookie with smoothie
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good
thank
job
so much
i finally worn
[Music]
you